Cats.
Pancakes.
Cats eating pancakes.
How are we actually supposed to
capture all this great content
without amazing camera
support in your apps?
I'm David East,
and Camera2 API is
for building the best in
the business camera apps.
Let's take a step back and look
at the history of the Camera
API options on Android.
The simplest option for
taking photos or video
has always been
the camera intent.
Basically, you kick
off this intent,
and the user gets to use
their preferred camera
app to take a picture.
While it's easy to
use, it's not really
for a heavyweight camera apps.
The camera intent
is for apps where
the camera is more
of an accessory
rather than the main
feature, and that
doesn't help us show
Fluffy eating flapjacks,
so we need a better API.
The Camera API provided
a lot more control
than the camera intent.
With the Camera API, you
could build a camera view
however you wanted, and
the Camera API was great.
But as photos progressed,
there were definitely
some things that it was
missing, like no support
for capturing uncompressed
images and performance
on newer hardware,
where the preview
rate was capped at, like, one
to three frames per second.
Clearly, our cats
deserve a better API.
And that API is Camera2.
The Camera2 API is the newest,
biggest, and baddest Camera API
on the block.
It provides you with an
awesome full [INAUDIBLE]
of control over your
device's cameras.
And it fixes all the problems
we had with our old API.
You can take images at faster
intervals, show previews
from multiple cameras, and even
apply effects and filters to it
directly.
However, before you get
hacking on your new camera app,
there are a few things
that you should know.
Just because the Camera2
API is overflowing
with awesome
features, it doesn't
mean that all of your users'
devices will support them.
As such, you need to
know what each device is
capable of doing,
and you can do that
by getting a list of the
camera characteristics specific
to that device.
These characteristics
can be simple things,
like which way the
lens is facing,
or something even more complex,
like the available face
detection modes.
And if your app can't function
without those features,
you can require that
the user must have it
in order to download your app.
Just set the user's feature
in your manifest file.
It's also important to know that
the Camera2 API was introduced
in Android L. In order to
support all their apps,
you're going to have to
fall back to the Camera API.
And there's no support for
the Camera2 API in the Android
Support Library just yet, but
if you bug this guy enough,
it might make it there
just a bit faster.
The Camera2 API give you
a lot of responsibility
over your device's cameras.
But with great responsibility
comes great power.
I think that's how it goes.
To learn about the Camera2 API,
check out the API reference.
And if you want to
see it in action,
there's a sample app on GitHub
that captures raw images.
If your app uses the camera,
get the best camera experience
using Camera2, and just
keep building better apps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]